things are looking grim for the
presidential candidacy of swollen
Nicolas Cage character Donald Trump and
he's responding and wrapping poll
numbers by softening his rhetoric and
taking a more recent compassionate tone
with his speeches I'm just with you he's
headed back to bed buffet for another
heaping helping of jingoistic nonsense
here he is talking about his cool new
immigration policy I call it extreme
thing I call it a scream extreme a very
but I'm a little a little unclear on
that what kind of betting was that was
that just normal run-of-the-mill vetting
or extreme
oh yeah the kids love heavy vetting now
this totally bitchin new policy would
require immigrants to take an intense
loyalty test to prove their as America's
enough for Trump's US of A I guess if
this questionnaire becomes a reality
what's a question you think Trump might
put on it Maz Jobrani he's gonna say I'm
gonna do some word association with you
I'm gonna give you a word you say the
first thing that comes to your mind I'll
o Akbar all right Gina I think he's
gonna ask some hard questions see if you
can catch her out it'd be like would he
prefer hot dogs and fireworks on the
fourth of july or sep tember the 11th oh
no John doar he'd probably say are you a
rapist I mean Mexican